façonnez le sable avec ses doigts pour
en faire du vert c'est ce qu'il fait
depuis 15 ans une passion pour le verre
fusionné qu'il en a fait son métier le
vert fusionné parce qu'il me permettait
de travailler le relief des vers et que
j'avais envie non seulement de
travailler sur le mouvement de la
lumière par rapport au vitraux et ce que
j'avais envie également c'était que le
mouvement des spectateurs lui-même
influent sur la vision qui va avoir du
travail une vision qui s'arrondit avec
les formes de ses œuvres puisqu’elles
représentent pour la plupart des ronds
comme des ondes de ricochet dans l'eau
j'essaye de donner un sens à mon travail
pas uniquement de décoration et je
travaille sur les forces fondamentales
de la nature et ce lien qu'on a
intimement avec ses forces fondamentales
puisqu'elle constitue notre
corps physique et ensuite formellement
c'est aussi intéressant parce que c'est
une forme stable et que dans mes pièges
j'essaye de d'avoir des des pièces qui
sont plutôt apaisantes stables
que des choses qui vont être en
déséquilibre combler les ouvertures avec
la profondeur la transparence et la
couleur une idée qu'il mette en lumière
en créant des vérandas des fenêtres mais
aussi du mobilier comme des tables ou
encore des assiettes je vais plutôt
utiliser des couleurs qui vont être plus
contrastées avec des couleurs qui sont
moins dans la nature comme le bleu des
bleu foncé le rouge qui en plus la
caractéristique de très bien fonctionner
en entre elles
mais je vais quelquefois aussi avoir du
jaune qui se retrouve moins dans la
nature il y a une spécificité du travail
du vert c'est qu'on travaille la
transparence et il y a des choses bien
particulières
qui vont se passer par rapport à un
travail sur des sur des couleurs opaque
par exemple un art qui est très demandé
par les architectes et les designers
mais aussi par des particuliers qui
viennent avec leurs projets pour faire
rentrer la lumière au cœur de la maison